well the president has made very clear
that he believes that Hillary Clinton is
the key to securing his legacy she was a
close colleague and staff member of his
during his first administration and he
believes that putting her forward will
be a very important part of securing his
legacy and moving forward through it so
he has gone aggressively to push her out
there and so he is confronting her
emails which is a major vulnerability
for her voters routinely cited and he is
pushing back against that it's worth
noting here that he is stating a fact
there was no deal between the State
Department and the FBI it may be that
one was sawed or it does seem from the
FBI notes that one was sawed but it
never happened that the email that they
were talking about not classifying was
classified and is kept from full public
release to this day yet at the same time
it must be kind of uncomfortable for the
Clinton campaign that her surrogates
whether it's President Obama Michelle
Obama Bill Clinton they end up having to
play a lot of defense talking about the
the email scandal as opposed to focusing
on really pushing why Hillary Clinton is
the candidate to vote for come November
sure absolutely and this has been a
problem throughout the campaign where
the Democrats feel that they have to be
on defense again and again it's with the
emails this is something that both
animates voters and that the Clinton
campaign maybe didn't come out and get
out in front of quite fast enough in
terms of having her explain what had
happened and apologizing for so that is
certainly something that's gone on but
you heard there the president referring
to Donald Trump as a whiner that is an
attack that a lot of Democrats believe
is actually quite effective because it
cast Donald Trump as somebody who is
kind of little and these belittling
attacks tend to bring out personal
responses for him when he's being
personal he's not hitting Hillary
Clinton and he is not portraying himself
as presidential he's not portraying
himself as leader he's not portraying
himself as common collected and the
Democrats think that's very effective
Ben when we look at some more the
information from the WikiLeaks dump one
of them was a list of potential the sort
of the first cut for VP candidates that
Miss Clinton and her staff were looking
at obviously the choice has been made
but
give us any insight into the sort of
mindset or the main priorities that this
administration could have sure
absolutely any smart campaign is trying
to grow itself with its vice
presidential pick they may come out and
they may say no it's only about fitness
on day one or it's about fitness with
the top of the ticket but the truth of
the matter is they are trying to expand
their horizons campaign chairman John
Podesta refers to these vice
presidential candidates that you're
seeing on your screen as falling into
food groups he is a foodie and so he has
gone for the food metaphor here he and I
share that but you're talking about at
Latino politicians African American
politicians you're talking about men
you're talking about women you're
talking about traditional politicians
military leaders and business leaders
they are looking at all of those and
they are trying to figure out we believe
they don't go into the pros and cons of
each one but we can see from the list
that they were trying to keep a very
open mind about how they might be able
to expand their coalition by choosing a
vice-presidential nominee and a running
mate and perhaps we should watch what
they do not wait they say because when
it comes to how the Clinton campaign is
spending their money they're now
starting to divert some of their money
to the red states states that previously
the Democrats wouldn't have had a shot
in winning absolutely it's not clear
exactly right now how much it's a faint
how much they're trying to play mind
games with the Republicans maybe draw
some support some money from the
Republicans away from typical
battleground states but the polling does
show us that the races are getting
closer in some traditionally red states
especially Arizona and the Clinton
campaign has talked a lot especially
yesterday about going there about
sending surrogates and potentially even
about sending the candidate herself to
do events to bring money and to help
down ballot candidates